who's now mob related murder mysteries
it's getting juicy now that's the focus
of this week's las vegas weekly cover
story
joining us staff writer cindy moon reed
cindy what a fun assignment let's talk
unsolved murder mysteries starting with
casino exec
gus greenbaum yeah so he was a mobbed up
casino exec
that started becoming a little bit
unpredictable
and maybe was skimming from the skimmers
so
it's okay to skim for the mob but you
can't skim
from the mop of course very important
distinction
so yeah he was found he and his wife
were found
murdered in phoenix and the mystery has
never been solved of who's done it
wow all right what about respected
lawyer bill coulthard am i saying his
name correctly
um i certainly hope so
so he was actually like one of the first
if not the first
fbi agents in las vegas and then he
became a lawyer
and his murder was unusual because it
happened in the middle of the day
in a parking garage in a bank in
downtown
las vegas and so it really
shocked the local community and um
there's different theories regarding um
was it to do
with a rental dispute regarding property
and different uh mobbed up hitman might
have done it but
ultimately uh nothing has ever been
pinned down so it is
unsolved to this day wow well you also
take a
real in-depth look at famous mobster
bugsy siegel my goodness
yes he's definitely the face of the las
vegas mob
and the real question is who would have
wanted to kill
him in the 1940s and
there's so many people actually that
wanted to kill him it's kind of
hard to think who was it it could have
been involved with like
the casino wire he was dating this mob
sweetheart
virginia hill and
and he was um he was abusing her so it
could have been for that
and um but the main the main theory is
that he was either skimming money or
mismanaging money at the flamingo casino
when it was starting out and so
um they did the ultimate hostile
takeover
oh wow okay well i we could go on and on
with this my goodness but we have time
for one more let's go
solve murders oh you covered the head of
the culinary union and the infamous
mobster frank colada he came on the
morning show he was a great interview he
really turned his life around after
prison didn't he
yeah so um this was a career criminal
who
went to prison outlived the mob and then
came back to vegas
to write books give mob tours uh sneak
at the mob museum
his last book was post published
posthumously
it was actually a cookbook and
unfortunately he died of covid this
august
all right thank you very much cindy moon
reed for your time today
of course grab a copy of las vegas
weekly mob museum
is a great resource for all the history
of organized crime and all the ties here
to our area
and we look forward to our next
interview with you we'll see you later
cindy take care
take care bye thank you christian it
looks so good doesn't it good stuff
there yeah thank you